ahora vamos a usar las condiciones
iniciales para encontrar los valores de
nuestras constantes a1 y a2 que se
encuentran en nuestra solución propuesta
para la corriente del circuito lc algo
que tenemos que hacer ya que esta es una
ecuación de segundo orden necesitamos
tener dos condiciones iniciales para la
variable que estamos estudiando en este
caso y en ese momento sólo tenemos una
condición inicial para iu y ya que esta
es una ecuación diferencial ordinaria de
segundo orden
vamos a necesitar dos condiciones
iniciales para ahí ya tenemos una
condición inicial aquí y queremos saber
cuál es el dt cuando el tiempo es igual
a cero el otro dato que tenemos aquí es
este de cero para el voltaje cuando el
tiempo es igual a cero vamos a usarlo y
a sustituirlo directamente en la
ecuación del inductor la ecuación del
inductor cuando t es igual a cero el
voltaje que pasa a través del inductor
es de cero y es igual a l
de ahí de lo que significa que del dt es
igual a cero entre l ahora ya tenemos
dos condiciones iniciales para ir aquí
tenemos una y aquí tenemos la otra y
ahora podemos usarlas para encontrar a1
y a2 primero sustituyamos ahí cuando te
es igual a cero y luego veamos si
podemos encontrar algo aquí cuando el
tiempo es igual a cero la corriente es
cero y es igual a 1 por el coche no de
omega 0 por t perote es igual a cero así
que lo multiplicamos por 0 más a 2 por
el seno de omega 0 por t perote es igual
a 0 así que es omega 0 x 0 y esto a que
es igual
esto es seno de cero y el seno de 0 es
igual a cero esto de acá es el coseno de
cero y el coche no de cero es igual a 1
lo que nos da que 0 es igual a 1
si aún no es 0 quiere decir que todo
este término de nuestra solución se va a
cero por lo que nos quedamos con y
iguala a 2 por seno de omega 0 t todo
este término desaparece de la solución
así que nos queda esta solución
propuesta ahora tenemos que encontrar a
como pueden sospechar vamos a usar
nuestra segunda condición inicial así
que para usar nuestra segunda condición
inicial tenemos que trabajar con del dt
así que vamos a calcular la derivada con
respecto al tiempo de toda esta ecuación
del lado izquierdo nos queda de bt igual
a de dt de a 2 por el seno de omega 0 t
continuemos y tenemos que del dt es
igual a 2 ya que esta es una constante y
sale de la derivada y la derivada de
seno omega 0 t con respecto a t es omega
0 por el coseno de omega 0 t ahora
usamos nuestra condición inicial vayamos
a cuando te es igual a 0 y sabemos que
el dt es de 0 / l que es igual a 2 omega
0 coseno de omega 0 t y como t es igual
a 0 lo multiplicamos por 0 y el coseno
de 0 es igual a 1
ahora despejamos a 2 a 2 es igual a de
cero entre el iomega serova en el
denominador y ya encontramos nuestro
segundo parámetro ajustable recordamos
que nuestra solución propuesta era igual
a 2 por el seno de omega 0 t y ahora
sustituimos a 2 por lo que va a ser
igual a de cero entre el omega 0 por el
seno de omega 0 t y ahora vamos a
sustituir el valor que teníamos para
omega 0 y si recuerdan dijimos que omega
0 era igual a la raíz cuadrada de 1
entre l por c así que el omega 0 es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 1 entre l
por c por l lo que es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de l al cuadrado
/ l porsche
y esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de l
entre c
finalmente escribimos que uno entre el
omega 0 es igual a la raíz cuadrada de c
entre l al recíproco y ahora podemos
escribir ahí como que es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de c entre el porve 0 seno de
omega 0 t y esta es la solución para la
respuesta natural de un circuito el ecce
tiene la forma de una onda senoidal la
frecuencia está determinada por omega 0
que son los valores de ambos componentes
y la amplitud está determinada por la
energía con la que comenzamos que está
representada aquí por b 0 y por la
proporción de ambos componentes también
y es por esto que al principio dije que
es aquí en donde nacen las senoidal es